The major source of all inflammation
in the body is actually the gut.
So your gut hosts the largest number
of immune cells in the body.
So that your most of the immune cells in your body
are found in your gut.
You've got them in your spleen, your thymus,
and your obviously in your blood.
So in addition to immune cells, being in your gut
you also have a lot of bacteria in your gut.
And those bacteria play a very, very important role
in regulating your immune system.
So you're talking about people that are eating unhealthy
and they're not getting enough fiber and you know
they're doing damage in the gut and that's causing
a lot of immune cells to become active
chronically every day.
You have to feed those bacteria the right types of foods.
You can kind of think of them as little chemical
producing factories actually
because when you feed them the right type of food,
which happens to be fiber,
fiber gets digested by this bacteria in your gut,
in your colon specifically
and it produces a bunch of different chemical products
called short chain fatty acids,
which are little signaling molecules
that tell your immune cells in your gut
to become a certain type of immune cell.
So they'll tell them,
okay become this type of immune cell that is involved
in preventing auto-immune diseases
making sure your immune system doesn't get so ramped up
that it starts to just attack everything
including your own organs.
That's very important.
That's Dr. Rhonda Patrick.
And this is a special Deep Dive edition
of the Rich Roll Podcast.
The Rich Roll Podcast.
And now for something a little bit different
after eight years and 500 plus conversations
I've compiled quite a library of bankable
timeless information and advice.
However, because of the way the Internet functions
and or the way the human animal operates
there does seem to be this sense that content created
in the past is somehow less meaningful
than more currently published content.
In many ways, this is incorrect.
And so to rebut this falsehood,
I felt compelled to better organize the best
of our 1,000 plus our audio library and over time,
convert it into a more helpful, productive, accessible
and hopefully practical resource for all of you.
And one of the several ways
of accomplishing this involves tapping this archive
to create episodes organized, not around a guest
but instead around a single theme or subject matter.
This episode is an initial experiment
and doing just that
the first in what will be an evolving series
of Deep Dives beginning with today's exploration
of The Microbiome courtesy of a collection
of gut health experts that have graced the show in the past.
Couple of more things to say about all of these,
but first only a little over a week remains
to take advantage of our new year's discount
on the plant power meal planner.
So if you would like unlimited access
to thousands of amazing plant-based recipes customized
to your preferences,
if you would also like all of the groceries
to prepare said recipes automatically delivered to your door
plus tons more awesome features
all for just $1.50 a week,
then here's the thing you kind of have to act now
at least before midnight, January 31st
by going to meals.richroll.com.
Use promo code POWER20@CHECKOUT.
And you my friends will save $20 off an annual membership.
That's meals.richroll.com promo code POWER20
for $20 off an annual membership
to our plant power meal planner.
While we're at it, we're supported today
by Calm, the app designed to help you ease stress
and get the best sleep of your life.
Because as I'm personally always hammering home solid shut I
is honestly the easiest and one of the most effective ways
to improve your overall health and happiness.
And Calm has a whole library of programs
specifically designed to enhance healthy sleep
like soundscapes, guided meditations,
and over a hundred sleep stories narrated by soothing voices
like Stephen Fry, the delightful Laura Dern,
and of course the hypnotic draw of Mr. Matthew McConaughey.
Over 85 million people around the world use Calm
to take care of their minds and to get better sleep.
To help you transform the way you sleep,
Calm is offering a special limited time promotion of 40% off
a Calm premium subscription at calm.com/richroll.
That's 40% off unlimited access to Calm's entire library
and new content is added every week.
So get started today at calm.com/richroll.
That's calm.com/richroll.
We're also brought to you today by my Finnish Fungi friends
at Four Sigmatic.
For the past, I don't know, like six years at this point,
I have been starting my day with either
their cortisol coffee,
which is amazing pre-workout or if I need to sit at a desk
or stand at a standing desk and write or think creatively
my go-to is their ground mushroom coffee with lion's mane.
I love it.
I love how it gives me focus, how it supports creativity.
And I love the even keeled energy boost
without the midday crash.
That my friends is the beauty
of my favorite functional mushroom lion's mane.
And also I might add chaga.
These things keep the caffeine under control
to support clean, focused energy.
I know what you're thinking.
Does this coffee tastes like mushrooms?
Of course it must.
It's made out of mushrooms.
No, it does not.
It tastes just like good coffee, period.
And right now you can receive
10% off your Four Sigmatic order.
Now is the perfect time to try
Four Sigmatic best-selling mushroom coffee
or any of their other delicious products.
Just go to foursigmatic.com/roll
or use promo code ROLL@CHECKOUT.
That's F-O-U-R-S-I-G-M-A-T-I-C.com/roll
to receive 10% off your order.
Okay, well, I've said this many times before
but because it is so mind-blowing
I think it's worth repeating and here it is.
Only about 1/2 our cells are actually human.
The other 1/2 is comprised of all the bacteria,
the viruses and the fungi that live in or on our bodies.
And we choose to believe nonetheless, that
despite the fact that we're the symbiotic host
of essentially an entire kingdom of life
that nonetheless we're still fully sentient
and self-governing that we're entirely responsible
for our health or moods or decisions
but the truth of course is far different.
And in fact, to a large extent, our emotional state
our propensity for disease, the nature of our cravings
and even some of our decision-making can be traced back
to the nature of our gut ecology.
Most of these microorganisms, as I said, a moment ago
are symbiotic maintaining a healthy culture
of the right microorganisms is fundamental to good health
but should the quality of your microbiome go awry
health havoc is certain to ensue.
So to better understand the vital role,
these microorganisms play in our health and our lives,
today's show is intended as a microbiome masterclass,
courtesy of the gastroenterologists,
the scientific researchers, and various gut experts
that have graced the show in the past.
The full episodes for whom can be found
in the show notes of course.
We begin today with a basic definition of the microbiome,
the vital functions, microbes play in regulating our bodies,
how antibiotic use can compromise our gut flora
and in turn our immune systems
and the adverse effects of over sanitation.
All of this is coming to you courtesy of my awesome friend
Dr. Robynne Chutkan respected integrative
gastroenterologist, microbiome expert,
and best-selling author of books that include "Gut Bliss"
and "The Microbiome Solution."
(piano music)
So probably the first thing we should do is
define what the microbiome is.
So it's basically the trillions of bacteria
that live in and on our bodies.
Mostly bacteria, but also viruses and protozoa
and helmets worms for those of us who have them.
So about 100 trillion and all.
100 trillion and how many human cells are we?
We are outnumbered 10:1-
10:1.
By our microbial cells and genes, yes.
So is this crazy thing
where we're really just hosts
to something that outnumbers us 10:1.
It's crazy when you start to think of it that way.
And there's this idea that
when we talk about the microbiome, we're really talking
about the gut bacteria, but really it applies
to everything that's on our skin and our hair,
like you know, our biggest organ, obviously our skin, right?
And the ecosystems really vary tremendously.
So even on your skin,
the bacteria that live in your nasal labial folds
close to the nose and mouth are completely different
to the bacteria that live on your cheekbones
a couple inches away on the same part of your face.
So it is the microbes from the gut to the vaginal milleu
to the lungs, to the mouth,
to, again just a couple inches away on the skin
are all completely different based
on the differences in moisture and oxygen content
and sweat glands and all sorts of things.
So pretty fascinating, the different landscapes.
And really the idea is that
most of these microorganisms are not foe.
They're a friend or they're kind of like neutral, right?
Yes, exactly.
And how did you first become interested in this?
So my area of expertise or interest
is inflammatory bowel disease,
Crohn's disease and ulcerative colitis
and those diseases Crohn's, which is sort of
the prototypical inflammatory bowel disease
was described by Doctors,
KRS-One Oppenheimer and Ginsburg in the 1930s
at Mount Sinai Hospital, where I did my GA training.
And we still, you know, almost 100 years later
just a little short of 100 years later
we're not really that much closer to figuring out
what cause these diseases
like most autoimmune diseases and medical community.
It's sort of like, well you just have them,
there's a genetic predisposition
but they're not really genetic diseases.
So I was seeing a lot of these patients and I
like a lot of other people in this area started noticing
that many of them have this common thread
of frequent antibiotic use.
So I started asking and people would say,
yeah, well I was on a bunch of antibiotics for strep throat
but that was decades ago.
Or I took tetracycline for acne in my teens
but what does that have to do with me having colitis now
or Crohn's now in my 30s?
And then there was an article
a meta analysis look at compilation
of many different studies from Mount Sinai
that came out and actually showed that antibiotic use,
interestingly, the two antibiotics that we use
to treat these diseases
were main risk factors for developing them.
So I just started to have this really uncomfortable feeling
like, you know, we're creating disease and not realizing it.
And we really have to let people know I would
see patients coming in and they tell me they've been
on antibiotics for acne for three or four years.
And low and behold, now they were developing GI symptoms.
And there didn't seem to be a really clear connection
between those things in the mind of the people
who were experiencing it.
And certainly not in the minds
of the doctors who were prescribing.
And I'd been one of those doctors up until very recently.
So I felt this very strong urge to
spread the word a little bit.
And unlike my first book, "Gut Bliss"
which probably 90% of the stuff
in the book I knew and was just my daily experience
seeing patients with GI problems and very little research
"The Microbiome Solutions" was sort of the opposite.
I learned so much writing this book.
I had this basic idea that we were on the wrong path
that we again were thinking
of our microbes as foes rather than friends
but I had no idea how much of the wrong path we were on
until I really started researching it.
Interesting.
So let's explain maybe, or explore a little bit about
the function of a healthy microbiome
and what kind of biological functions it helps regulate?
And in terms of like keeping us healthy
or leading us astray from health.
So you talked about us being host
to the microbes.
If you think of our body as a factory
and all these different things have to happen,
the kidneys have to filter urine.
The heart has to pump the lungs
have to swap carbon dioxide for oxygen.
The digestive tract has to break down food
into its constituent parts of protein
and fat and carbohydrate
and then absorb them through the lining
and carry them to the different organs for energy.
All that stuff has to be done by some things, someone.
And those, somethings someones our microbes.
So they are sort of the worker bees for the factory
that help all these processes keep running smoothly,
not just in the gut.
Of course, that's where we, as you said
that's where the majority of the microbes are
but in all kinds of different areas too.
So if we think about something like energy for cells,
energy for cells in our digestive tract
colonocytes what do they use for energy?
They use short chain, fatty acids.
Where do the short chain fatty acids come from?
They're byproducts of the microbes
break them down and provide the shirt chain.
Yes, exactly.
Producing vitamins.
There are a whole bunch of essential vitamins
that our bodies can't make on their own.
That gut bacteria are involved in methylation processes
to create these vitamins
the clear toxins from your body,
cancer causing toxins, some less aggressive toxins.
So there all these vital functions
I mean, really, you know, at its core,
essentially what you're saying is sort of maintaining
this healthy gut flora and, you know, microbial ecology
that you know, propagates all over your body
is absolutely essential to maximizing health
and preventing disease et cetera.
But this is sort of at odds with kind of the last several
decades of medicine and this kind of over-sanitisation
of not only our environments, but our bodies.
And with that, I would assume comes either
in ignorance of the important functions of the microbiome
or just a sense of it not being essential or important.
Is that fair to say?
That's absolutely fair.
So in the 1950s, a researcher
from the London School of Tropical Medicine and Hygiene,
named David Struan was tasked with trying to figure out
why they were seeing so much eczema and hay fever
which are sort of classic auto-immune diseases.
In post-industrial London, everybody had left the farm
for the factory and they were seeing this sort of epidemic.
And he found two really interesting.
It was a 27-year study looking at thousands of kids
and their families.
And he found two really interesting things.
Number one, kids who lived in large households
with lots of siblings had far fewer lower rates essentially
of hay fever and eczema
because they were sort of being immunized
by their siblings who were sneezing on them,
coughing on them, darting them up in general,
which we now know is a good thing.
And children who came from more affluent households
where there were higher standards of hygiene
or the bathing all the time washing all the time
things were super clean
had also higher rates of these things.
So it was good to be,
it was good to be in a larger litter,
if you will, with lots of litter mates
and it was not good to be too wealthy and too clean.
And at that time, I'm not suggesting
that people of higher socioeconomic status
are gleaner in general,
but that was a phenomenon post-industrial London
is that higher socioeconomic households
had more means had more access to these
sort of newer at the time hygienic modalities,
they had more showers and baths and so on.
So that was the beginning that formed the foundation
for something that's called the hygiene hypothesis
which basically says that our immune system needs exposure
to germs, to bacteria, for training so that it can recognize
and distinguish between friend and foe.
And when that doesn't happen
as was what was happening in post-industrial London
when people were starting to be cleaner
is that the immune system gets confused
and then it starts to react to its own body.
So in the case of the diseases I see,
Crohn's and ulcerative colitis, the body starts to react
to the gut tissue and creates ulcers and inflammation.
Right there autoimmune diseases.
Autoimmune and the case of arthritis,
it's a joint psoriasis and eczema it's a skin.
So there's a direct correlation between autoimmune diseases
and the level of hygiene and sanitation
as countries get more industrialized, more developed
and the level of sanitation and the use of
things like hand sanitizers and antibiotics and so on.
Fluoride chlorine in the water.
As that increases the rate of autoimmune diseases
start to increase.
And we're seeing this in India and the middle East.
And it's a real problem because again,
we have to figure out,
I mean, it's great chlorination of water help to eradicate
cholera outbreaks and so on.
So it's sort of a tough situation.
You don't want people drinking, dirty water and coming down
with outbreaks of cholera, but at the same time
with super sanitizer,
the water now it's full of chlorine and chemicals.
And again, it's one of these contributors
to auto-immune disease.
So there is a balance there between being safe
and not having large numbers of people exposed
to potentially harmful microbes
and just super sanitizing, everything and creating disease.
Right, yeah, it's like the pendulum
has swung too far.
Yeah.
I mean, certainly you want,
you know, a sanitary situation
in the event of like an acute infection, right?
You want like the surgery room
you want the instruments to be, you know, very sanitary
but we've kind of taken that idea
and run too far with it, right?
Like our pure culture is out of control.
And you know, the idea behind that is,
Oh if you want to not get sick
you want a germ-free environment.
But basically it turns out it's the opposite
like that kind of low grade continuous exposure
to all sorts of maybe pathogens is too extreme a word
but just, you know, the general environment
in which we live allows our immune system to respond
in kind of, you know, do its pushups so that it's prepared
for when the day comes, when you have that kind
of overexposure to something that might make you sick
so that your system can do what it needs to do.
That's exactly right.
Yeah, cool.
So if we track it through kind of like, you know
the lifespan of a typical individual starting at,
in utero, so coming through the vaginal canal
being born is extremely important.
You get that, like you get covered in all of this,
these microorganisms, you get a big gulp of it,
I suppose, as you're born.
And when you have a C-section, you're denied that
kind of like rite of passage of being born
that kind of coats you and stuff that you need to be as
sort of base in elementary about it as possible,
that will serve in kind of seeding your microbiome for,
better health as you mature.
And Rich, I went through medical school
and good places.
I was at Columbia for medical school residency.
I trained at Mount Sinai.
I had never heard this.
I heard this for the first time
at a center for mind body medicines,
food as medicine course.
And I couldn't believe it.
I mean, my jaw dropped.
I was like, what?
This is an important thing going through the vaginal canal.
I thought, how could, I mean, people, that's something
that people are much more aware of now, but I thought-
What percentage of people get C-sections?
It's now almost one in three in the US
and granted some of those are necessary breech births
and the mothers in distress or the baby's in distress.
But the vast majority, the vast majority are done
because of convenience and people don't know,
OBGYN don't know.
When I talked to some of my OBGYN colleagues about this
they looked at me like I have two heads.
They're like, what?
So we, again, you know, most physicians
and most people one could argue, it's slowly changing.
I think that the cleaner you are the better.
And as you said, there's some good times to be clean.
If you're having your leg amputated,
you're having your appendix out or something.
It's good to have a clean environment.
You don't want to rub dirt in the open wound.
Speaking of rubbing dirt and the open wound
there is a fantastic way to rewild a baby
who has been born by C-section
and that's just to take a little gauze swab and soak it.
And obviously it doesn't have to be sterile
because we're soaking it in microbes
and just sort of soak up the vaginal juices of the mother
and then wipe the baby down with it after
just to sort of try and approximate passing
through the vaginal canal.
It's such a simple low-tech way of doing it,
but instead what do we do?
You know, we yanked the babies out
after C-section and then we sort of sterilize them.
And we wipe them down with all the spectra cidal stuff.
So we really have to rethink what it means to be human
and to be healthy and our relationship with microbes
and this idea that the cleaner and the more sterile
the more chemicals we have in our environment
the healthier we are.
If you go down that road, you will end up
in a really bad place as far as your health is concerned.
Okay, so we got our footing
but we can't talk about the microbiome
without talking about prebiotics and probiotics.
But what exactly are these?
And do any of them actually make a difference
or is this just all marketing hype?
Well, to help cut through the confusion
I sat down with Ara Katz and Raja Dhir,
the co-founders of Microbiome Company Seed.
Let's define the term probiotic.
So probiotics are live microorganisms,
which confer a health benefit on the host.
There's a couple of key definitions
that are sub definitions within that.
The first is if it has not been tested
in the human population for the claim that's being made
then it is not a probiotic.
So that means double-blind randomized placebo
controlled studies, scientifically looking to show
that that organism has a probiotic effect.
One popular trick that we see a lot of commercial interests
and corporations use is they'll test a probiotic strain
for one very specific or small or niche outcome.
Like let's say, I don't know, antibiotic
associated diarrhea, for example,
but then they'll position the product
as if it has utility for a wide audience
preventively or proactively.
And there's just no information to suggest that.
So I think that we really want to see companies
and researchers, this isn't even just a company's thing.
This is the term and in the lexicon is views
and thrown around to basically capture any organism,
which could have a benefit
or that's theoretically could have a benefit
or even just anything that's been fermented.
That's how broad this category has gone,
where all fermented foods
are not being positioned as probiotic but-
Or lysates like in skincare.
Yeah, so lysates are organisms that are heat killed
and then ripped open.
And just the cell wall is being used and applied
and those are called probiotics all the time.
So it's very, very important
that the definition included the organisms being live
being delivered in the appropriate dosages
and having testing done on the indication
in the population that it's being marketed to.
Yeah, I mean, it goes back again a little bit
to the fact that the term itself is used so loosely
not just on products, but also from a dietary perspective
like Raja mentioned like fermented foods and beverages
a lot of people just say,
I'll drink a kombucha and I don't need to take a probiotic.
And I think that's partially just because
the term itself has become so diluted.
Meanwhile, it's an entire area of inquiry,
like you know, within microbiome science.
And I think it's especially important too,
because in the future, particularly as we look at areas like
you know, fertility, the treatment of pathology and disease
the way we're gonna metabolize chemotherapy
the way we're gonna think about vaginal health
and preterm birth in the developing world,
I mean probiotics have such potential
to make a huge, huge impact
and not just because of their health impact,
but also from the affordability
compared to other medications,
the lack of side effects compared to other medications
or other complications.
We really feel that they're such an important part
of our cause not just the science
and to create what we believe are some
of the most sophisticated and effective products
but to really steward the translation of it
and to really be able to call out,
you know evangelism over evidence.
You know, if everyone thinks that every tortilla chip
you can just throw a probiotics on
or your shampoo is just every,
just throw some microbes in and it's probiotic.
Obviously those things are not going to get taken seriously.
And actually as a result, you know, when we've seen areas
of science where public perception shapes
and hinders funding and the ability
to move some of these areas forward.
And so I think that for us like part of really big,
important part of the mission.
All right, so let's dispel misconceptions
around kind of what the typical sort of thought pattern is
or behaviors are around like the products
that are currently available.
So fermented foods, definitionally
are a very different category than a probiotic.
It would be considered a prebiotic, yes.
Unless it's been shown to modulate the microbiome.
It's not even a prebiotic.
It is just a fermented food.
That is the category.
And I'll give you an example.
So a study was done that did a deep metogenomic sequencing
on a kimchi product.
And of the 900 or so different strains that were found
from the lots that were tested,
only four are believed to have probiotic potential
or were advanced.
And to showing that it has probiotic potential.
I think that a lot of the benefits and fermented foods come
because of the bacteria actually pre digests a lot
of the components and rough edges
that for some people are very difficult to handle.
And their fibrous.
Their fibrous and they're delicious.
So this is not a PSA against fermented foods.
We think they're great and have been used
in ancestral populations for the purposes
of food preservation for a very, very long time.
If I didn't have a refrigerator
my diet would be 70% fermented foods.
But the fermentation process itself
is bacterial growth, right?
Are these not like sort of positive organisms
that we want to introduce into our microbiome or?
They don't stay there very long.
They don't colonise.
In fact, I would say more important than the organisms
that are used for fermentation are organic acids
and fermentation byproducts.
And some of those metabolites that we believe could be used
by the human body to have a health benefit
but these studies are few and far between.
And so the research is really, really lacking
And actually the way Raja is describing it
is like a really important distinction.
Just you were talking about how to like break this down
for like the general consumer looking at probiotics.
It's really important to think
about that a microbe could be taken.
So you could actually consume bacteria
to have a specific effect that it has been studied for,
which is very different
than the way probiotics are currently marketed,
which is this idea that it's good bacteria
that you have some good bacteria,
but that you're missing some in your gut
and that you take a probiotic and it puts it back,
which is two very different ways of thinking about them.
But the scientific definition is the former
which is that you consume bacteria that has been
demonstrated to have an effect in the human body.
And that's the difference, which is in the
where the marketing is right now,
is this notion that you kind of like restore
or put the good stuff back
versus that it has an effect in the body
and that by taking it continuously,
cause probiotics actually
Raja was talking about colonization
which is another good myth to bust.
And that there's a lot
of people who think that a probiotic must colonize
in order to "Work."
But in fact, probiotics are transient,
which means that they do their work
kind of on the road on their way through your body.
And so that's an important distinction that I think
a lot of people kind of don't understand.
Yeah.
What is the impact in your mind of the decreasing diversity
of our biosphere in general?
You know, through our soil, through the,
our increasingly toxic environment,
the way we raise animals for food, et cetera,
all of these things playing into species extinction,
all the way down to single cell organisms
and smaller, and the, like, how does this play
into gut health and how we think about these issues?
Yeah, I mean, well, you know, one of the things
that we are looking at from a seed perspective
and we have a division of our company called Seed Labs,
which is where we start to look at the way
in which microbes could be a part of the solution.
So like honeybees are like a really awesome example.
Yeah, you guys are doing something amazing.
Yes.
That's right.
This looks specifically at the impact
on the honeybee gut of new niche, no pesticides.
But on the honeybees I'll let Raja,
Raja can speak a little bit about the science.
I'll start by answering your question.
Most people here would know or have heard this phenomenon
called colony collapse disorder,
which is for unexplained reasons in the last 10 years
or so mass mass communities
of honeybees are just dying off indiscriminately.
We don't know why the populations are-
Do we really not know why?
We're starting, so that's the hook.
The answer is the lead two leading causes
or the three leading causes are habitat loss
and habitat doesn't just mean the wild is being less wild.
It means Monique plant culture of plants too.
So the streamlining of agriculture-
The lack of diversity that's exist now-
Lack of diversity.
The second is a pathogen called fallowed root disease.
It's a nasty pathogen that kills honeybee babies
in the first three days of life.
And the third are neonicotinoid pesticides
which the EU had banned last year, but the US still allows.
And they're called because they operate
in the nicotinoid and nicotinic receptor sites
in the brain, which etymologically are related
to what's found in the tobacco plant
so much so that if you put a suspension of water
with glucose and water with neonicotinoid pesticides
honeybees will pick the pesticide water over sugar water.
And that's a completely crazy finding.
And so what it does is it slowly disorients bees.
And when it compounds and aggregates in their bodies
they just get so disoriented
that they forget where their hive is.
So this thesis was when these environmental changes happen,
the first thing that changes is the microbiome.
And so there's a lot of sequencing work that was done.
Our chief scientists and our first seed fellow
are the ones that are leading these field trials.
And we actually found that
by reintroducing three probiotic organisms
back into the bee gut
you can a detoxify neonicotinoid pesticides
before they're absorbed into the body.
So it's, it binds and releases these common pesticides
and dampens or protects the immune response as a result
of it, but perhaps more impressively
in early, early bee communities.
You know, so bees are becoming something
like Japan right now, where there's a lot of old bees
but very few young bees.
And they dramatically insignificantly protect
these young bees from crowding out this pathogen,
which is so powerful that if it's found
beekeepers are supposed to go and burn and scorched earth,
the entire hive, to make sure that it doesn't-
Within days.
Within days of its discovery
cause it can spread very quickly
even one spore can spread and result in an epidemic
and in a neighboring hive.
So we published about this.
The first paper came out in scientific reports
in nature using a soft flow model.
That's a model organism for honeybee populations,
field trials just concluded last year,
we made our announcement at the end of last year
and we patented this, but then opened up royalty-free
the patent to honeybee farmers around the world.
And then we hope at some point this year
to roll out bio patties and bio sprays
that are based off these species after
our UC Davis trial commences.
And so this is a large scale of field trial in almond farms,
which is kicking off in a couple of months.
So essentially it's a probiotic-
Right now it's a patty.
It's like almost like it's like a pancake
that you put in the hive.
And so they eat it?
Yeah.
Okay, so they eat it in the hive
and that populates their gut flora
with something that helps them avoid the negative impacts
of these nicotinamide nicotine pesticides.
Of nicotine pesticides
and of the Fallbrook disease.
So two out of the three are leading causes
of colony collapse disorder
Right.
And just for people that don't know, paint a picture
of colony collapse disorder, you know, at its ultimate.
The bees are the most efficient pollinators
that have or ever will be discovered or invented.
If we lose bee populations
we lose nearly every single blooming crop
or fruiting crop that you find,
maybe some in small quantities root vegetables
would persist but a lot of the diversity that you see
from above ground pollination are virtually gone.
I mean, models that predict it
say that the supermarket, the fruits and vegetables
isles of the supermarket would be decreased
by over 90% if we lost that many bees.
Yeah.
I mean the easiest way to say it is whatever you ate
for breakfast this morning probably won't be here.
And there's also other implications like cotton
for example, that have of course other implications
for other industries and other uses
Right.
So it really broadens the aperture
on the work that you're doing.
This is not just,
Hey, you know like we want to create a probiotic
to make people healthy.
Like it's really an effort to address
the declining biodiversity of the planet at large
and that the implications or the sort of applications
of this science that you're developing are really limitless.
And I think also the applications of science
that's really often stays kind of guarded,
you know in academic institutions are for many reasons
often doesn't make its way to humans
or for other applications that can be immediately
kind of put to use and to make an impact.
So part of, kind of the bridge we've built
and very proud of.
(piano music)
Much more to come, of course,
but first today's episode is brought to you by Public Goods.
The one-stop shop for sustainable high quality
everyday essential is made from clean ingredients
at an affordable price.
Everything from coffee to toilet paper and shampoo
all the way to pet food even.
Public Goods is your new everything store
thoughtfully designed for the conscious consumer.
So rather than buying from a bunch of single product brands
public goods members can buy all their premium essentials
in one place with one beautiful streamlined aesthetic.
These days have been loving
their refillable shampoo and conditioners.
They're awesome.
And I just appreciate how public goods, ethically sources
and obsessively develops all of their products to be free
of unhealthy ingredients and harmful additives
knowing what's in your products
and where they come from is important.
Small changes in the way shop can make a big impact
on personal health and the world at large.
So let's get on to people right now.
You can receive $15 off your first public goods order
with no minimum purchase.
They are so confident
that you will absolutely love their products
and come back again and again
that they're essentially getting you $15
to spend on your first purchase.
You've got nothing to lose.
Just go to publicgoods.com/richroll
or use code RICHROLL@CHECKOUT.
That's P-U-B-L-I-C-G-O-O-D-S.com/richrolls
to receive $15 off your first order.
And finally, finally, we're brought to you by Outerknown
the makers of my all time, favorite, effortlessly cool
and supremely crafted sustainable staples made to last.
Founded by a pro surfer global icon at this point.
You know, this guy, Kelly Slater
Outerknown is setting a much needed new standard
in the fashion industry, making great clothes
that don't harm people or the environment.
They actually go to great lengths to ensure
that all of their fibers are planet friendly
and they only work with the cleanest factories
that pay fair living wages.
Lately, I'm all about their blanket shirt.
It's just super dang cozy.
I think this thing is going to last forever.
So when it's time for that wardrobe refresh,
I can't recommend more highly going to sustainable
Outerknown's collection of men and women's clothes.
This is what's happening now, people.
So go to outerknown.com today
and enter my code ROLL@CHECKOUT,
and you'll get 25% off your full price order.
That's outerknown.com O-U-T-E-R-K-N-O-W-N.com.
And remember to use my code ROLL@CHECKOUT for 25% off.
Check them out today.
That's outerknown.com
and don't forget promo code ROLL@CHECKOUT for 25% off.
Okay, to ease back into all of this.
I think it would be good to pull focus
on the link between how we treat our bodies
what we choose to put into our bodies
and what we absorb into our bodies
and how all of that impacts our guts,
specifically our gut lining
and the permeability of that gut lining.
And of course in turn downstream,
what all of that means in terms of health and disease.
Our steward for this corner of microbial exploration
is my friend and podcast standout favorite Dr. Zach Bush.
Truly one of the most interesting minds working today
to improve human and planetary health.
The first step is to kind of consider
what is inflammation.
Inflammation is actually a normal biologic response
to an injury.
The immune system lies throughout your body
in different shapes and forms, but some 60% of the volume
of the immune system and some 80% of the work done
by the immune system has done in your gut lining.
And the concept of the gut is poorly defined
and poorly understood by the consumer as well as doctors
but it really starts in your sinuses.
It is your barrier system between the outside world
and what you breathe the outside world
and what you drink, eat, et cetera.
This membrane is extremely interesting to look at it
and it's engineering.
It's such an interesting under engineering event,
this gut membrane.
It is the largest surface area we have exposure
to the outside world is two tennis courts in surface area
versus only the 1.8 meters or so of your skin surface area.
So you've got this massive surface area.
And the only covering of that surface
is a cellophane-like layer of epithelial cells
of the gut and sinuses and the rest
that is about 50 microns in diameter which-
That's like one cell thick, right?
One cell thick,
which is if you pluck a human hair and cut that in 1/2
that's the thickness of your gut membrane.
So you have this 1/2 a human hair cellophane layer
that protects you from every bite of food you eat,
every chemical that comes into your food chain, et cetera.
So it seems like horrible engineering, but on the flip side
it tells us something about what we're engineered for.
We need to be inherently
in contact with the ecosystem and nature around us.
And if we start to tinker and screw with that nature
that membrane is gonna become very vulnerable
and start to leak.
And our immune system sits right behind that.
There had been some papers coming out in the mid 2000s
in the cancer world that were starting to say that
the bacteria in your gut were predicting
which cancers you would get.
If you're missing these bacteria
you would get prostate cancer.
If you have these bacteria, you would get breast cancer.
That was so radically bizarre
and out there for our current model
even to this day as to how cancer worked.
But now you fast forward eight, 10 years
and now there's tens of thousands
of articles that are showing that genomically
the bacterial genome is way more important
in determining cancer than the human genome.
And so this reality was hitting in.
So in 2012, when we discovered these chemicals
that look a little like chemotherapy
that are made by bacteria and fungi in the soil
it suddenly closed the loop of,
Oh my gosh what if the bacteria in our gut
is doing the same thing?
What if the bacteria and the fungi are actually
our best source of medicine for everything.
And so that's the direction we were going.
But as soon as we put this into Petri dishes
with cancer cells and beyond, we suddenly realized,
no, no no, there's something way deeper happening
with this information stream
coming out of bacteria and fungi.
And it was my chief science officer, Dr. John Gilday
is a PhD in genetics and cell biology.
And he was the first to realize that we had put our finger
on the glyphosate toxicity issue
as that this communication network
from the bacteria and fungi was actually
supporting the protein structure in our gut lining.
And so it turns out that the gut is held together
as these trillions of cells
that make up that cellophane layer by tight junctions.
These are Velcro like proteins that hold one
microscopic cell to the next, to create this coherent carpet
of two tennis courts.
And he had recognized before this and a number
of other labs that started to publish that glyphosate
seemed to increase the permeability of this membrane.
And nobody was really sure why yet that chemical
was never patented as a weed killer.
It's only been patented as an antibiotic,
and then it was re patented
as an anti parasite and it was fungi-
Yeah that was the original purpose of it, correct?
What's the mechanism,
and it's the mechanism they recognized.
And so the mechanism of glyphosate is to go in
and block enzymes in soil bacteria, fungi, and plants.
And that enzyme pathway is called the shikimate pathway.
And it's important because it makes a number
of the essential amino acids.
Our bodies are composed of over 200,000 proteins
but we only have 20,000 genes.
We have this pathetically dumb genome
in the sense that a flea has 30,000 genes.
So you're 2/3 as complicated as a flea at the gene level,
which I find reassuring.
If I can't find my keys or I'm having a bad day,
I'm like, hey, I'm 2/3 complicated as a flea
what can I, what are my real expectations here?
But the reality is we're very simple at the genetic level.
And yet we make over 200,000 proteins
from a bunch of amino acids.
There's 26 amino acids that will build
those 200,000 proteins.
Those 26 amino acids are just like
the 26 letters of the English alphabet
in the sense that the vast majority of those are useful,
but not critical,
but the vowels, these eight vowels in our language
if you subtract one of those vowels,
you can affect hundreds of thousands of words.
The vowels and the amino acid vocabulary here
are the essential amino acids,
which if you start to tweak any of those nine
you're gonna start to lose tens
of thousands of protein structures
in their functionality and in their unique form.
And so those essential amino acids
not only are they important like the vowels
they also can't be made by the human body.
So those nine have to come from your food chain somewhere.
And it turns out that they are only made by the bacteria,
the fungi, and the plants.
You don't have a shikimate pathway in your human cells.
And so these essential amino acids are blocked
through the shikimate pathway by roundup.
And so imagine treating a food chain
with a chemical that blocks the ability
of these plants to make the building blocks
for a healthy human body forget about a human,
it's a dog, a cat, any mammal,
any complex multicellular biology is gonna depend
on these essential amino acids.
And we literally, in the last 15 years
subtracted out the ability to build the body
because we changed the 26 letters.
Zach spoke about inflammation
but it's still kind of an elusive confusing subject matter.
I want to better understand it.
What does it mean?
Why is it so important,
and what is the difference between acute inflammation?
Like what happens when you suffer a physical injury
and chronic inflammation,
which is this persistent state that can be
and often is induced by things like diet and lifestyle?
And on the subject of diet,
how exactly does diet itself affect the gut bacteria
and in turn the immune system
and how does all of this relate to inflammation?
Well, here's the wonderful Dr. Rhonda Patrick,
a PhD in biomedical sciences and an expert in nutrition,
metabolism and aging to break it all down
in understandable terms.
I don't think a lot of people
really do understand exactly what inflammation is.
So what inflammation is referring to is it's a consequence
of your immune system being activated.
And once your immune system is activated
they start firing off all these chemical weapons
that are called inflammatory cytokines.
And these inflammatory cytokines are damaged cells
inside your body, damage DNA inside your body,
damaged pretty much everything inside of your cells.
But what's confusing to me about this
is that essentially inflammation
is an immune system response
to something wrong in your body, right?
It's your body's way of saying, let's send the ambulance
out to fix whatever's wrong.
Whether you cut your finger or you sprained your knee,
your immune system gets activated and mobilized
to then kind of visit that either localized area
or in general if it's stress-related
or something like that, I suppose.
But the idea behind it is to fix the problem, right?
So on some level, doesn't it make sense that like
some inflammation is good
because it's your body reacting to a problem
in order to fix it?
Absolutely.
One of the major downstream effects
of having these inflammatory cytokines and molecules
being produced is they recruit other repair factors.
It increases genes in your body
that then start to repair damage, fix things.
So it's an essential part of repair and recovery system.
However, there is a difference between acute inflammation
and chronic inflammation.
Acute inflammation would be something
like your four hour marathon run, you know
or your two hour training session when you're running
and you're causing inflammation there,
you know inflammation occurs after intense exercise.
That's good because the inflammation signals to various,
genes in your body that turn on all these antioxidant genes.
They turn on genes, that repair muscle damage,
they turn on all these good.
So it's like a stress response sort of mechanism
where you're turning on all the good stuff
but you need the bad stuff to turn them on.
So it's kind of like here's a little dose of this bad stuff
to turn on the good stuff.
Right.
So there's sort of the exercise induced,
oxidative stress that triggers the immune system response
versus somebody just smoking cigarettes all day long
and that's causing some kind of internal damage
in a number of ways that's creating
just a chronic immune system response that is literally
just burning your engine out, right?
Yeah, exactly.
You know, the chronic smoking
or actually the major, major source of all inflammation
in the body is actually the gut.
So you're talking about people that are eating unhealthy.
They're not getting enough fiber
and they're doing damage in the gut and that's causing
a lot of immune cells to become active
chronically every day.
So, in your experience what are the foods
that create the worst sort of inflammatory response?
Well, I think it's actually more a lack of food-
Lack of the good foods?
Than eating bad foods
because your gut hosts the largest number
of immune cells in the body.
So that your most of the immune cells in your body
are found in your gut,
you've got them in your spleen,
your thymus, and obviously in your blood stream.
But the largest number of them are actually in our gut.
The reason for that is because,
your gut is exposed to the external environment.
You know, the food you eat, your gut sees it.
And that can be pretty lethal
if you get some bad nasty stuff.
So your immune system has to be there
and ready to react to that.
To make sure that you stay alive along,
long enough to reproduce and pass on your genes.
So in addition to immune cells, being in your gut
you also have a lot of bacteria in your gut.
Tons and tons of bacteria.
And there's people that sort of debate
how many bacteria,
there's a hundred trillion
I've seen references for and I haven't dug into like,
is it accurate or not?
I mean, it's a lot, it's a lot of fricking bacteria.
10 times more microorganism than human.
And people, you know, that just can't,
it irks them to hear people say that.
And, you know, I don't know, I've seen references that show
that there are 100 trillion bacteria cells
in your colon, in the distal part of your gut.
And those bacteria play a very, very important role
in regulating your immune system.
So you have to feed those bacteria,
the right types of foods, in order for them,
you can kind of think of them
as little chemical producing factories actually
because when you feed them the right type of food
which happens to be fiber,
fiber gets digested by this bacteria in your gut,
in your colon specifically
and it produces a bunch of different chemical products
called short chain fatty acids,
which are little signaling molecules
that tell your immune cells in your gut
to become a certain type of immune cell.
So they'll tell them,
okay, become this type of immune cell that is involved
in preventing auto-immune disease is making sure
your immune system doesn't get so ramped up
that it starts to just attack everything
including your own organs.
That's very important.
And the type of immune cell that does it
it's called T regulatory cells
and T regulatory cells become T regulatory cells
based on this bacteria, in your gut that are producing
these little products that tell it to do it.
So it's very important that your gut gets fiber.
And if you look at like hunter gatherer societies
like in Tanzania, they get around 200 grams of fiber a day.
And compared to the typical American diet
which is like maybe 15 grams of fiber,
that's a huge-
Yeah, that's crazy.
And it's funny because in our culture
we're all obsessed with protein.
You know, we're all walking around thinking
that we might be suffering from a protein deficiency.
The truth is almost everyone is suffering
from a fiber deficiency.
And if we flip those words around
I think we'd all be better off.
If people were like, did you get your fiber today?
Did you get your fiber today?
I mean, we would be in a different place.
I am so with you on that is my new motto.
Did you get your fiber today?
Because it is so incredibly important
and what a good way to think about it
for some people that don't really have a grasp
on why fiber is so important,
when you eat protein, when you eat fat,
when you're eating these other sources of energy
even carbohydrates that are not fibre,
that you know like refined carbohydrates
that don't have fiber,
those things all get metabolized
in the upper part of your intestine.
They don't make it to the colon
where all your bacteria are,
probiotic bacteria, good bacteria, the commensal bacteria
that are regulating the immune system like I just mentioned.
So what happens is because you're getting protein and fat
and refined carbs, those bacteria start to get hungry.
Oh, what am I gonna eat?
I don't get the protein.
I don't get the fat.
So they actually start to eat.
What's called mucin
which is what it's essentially the gut barrier.
The gut barrier is made up something called mucin
and it's mucin cause it's kind of mucusy kind of slippery.
And it separates the immune cells from the bacteria
in your gut, separates the food, you know,
from the internal part of your gut.
So they've got barrier starts to get broken down
by your own probiotic bacteria that are good
for you because they're hungry
because you've been starving them of fiber.
Right, they're so far down the conveyor belt
that they have,
they're forced to basically cannibalize themselves.
Exactly.
And is that what causes leaky gut
and all these sorts of issues
where people are having all these
you know, digestive disorders?
Yes, it causes a plethora of disorders,
you know, leaky gut.
It affects your immune system
because now your immune system is all out of work.
Your gut barrier starts to break down,
the immune cells start to see the bacteria.
What do I mean cells do when they see bacteria?
They fire away.
They're gonna fire all that chemical warfare.
I was talking about creates more inflammation.
You start to release these things into your bloodstream,
causes activation of immune cells in your bloodstream
that can affect your cholesterol.
And, you know, the lack of fiber kind of like,
I think it's like this insidious kind of damage
that people just, they don't realize that it's like,
Oh they may notice they may be constipated a little,
or you know, it's just, but they don't realize
to what magnitude this sort of effect can have
when it starts to compound over the years.
Cause it's really changing your immune system.
It's causing inflammation, it's aging you,
it's going to accelerate the way you age on every level.
And you know, it can lead to these diseases
these autoimmune related diseases, these diseases of aging,
all sorts of problems start to happen.
And I really think that you nailed it
when there's a simple solution.
The simple solution is you need to focus on getting fiber.
I mean, I actually, that is my main obsession.
It's fiber, and then I supplement some protein
and fat and all that with fiber.
Right, fiber is at the top of the food pyramid.
It's at the top.
That's so interesting.
And it's all different types of fiber
because you've got you know, seeds, legumes,
you've oats, vegetables, fruits
you know, they all have different types of fiber.
And what we're learning is that there are different
types of fiber that are having different effects.
You know, so they're feeding different types of bacteria
and they're producing those bacteria
are producing different types of chemical byproducts
which then do X, Y, or Z.
You know, so I mentioned the T regulatory cells
which are important for preventing auto-immune disease.
They also make an something called natural T killer cells
which are the most important type of immune cell
that kills cancer cells in your body
when we're constantly getting little cancer cells that arise
and our immune system takes care of it.
It's sort of like a levels number
you know, when we get more cancer cells
than our immune system can handle a,
because our immune system's weak,
because we're not making enough natural killer cells
or something like that.
Then it starts to get to the point
where the cancer cells start to survive.
They make it.
Gotcha.
All right, good.
So let's get back to inflammation in general.
So we kind of have a working understanding
of inflammation now.
And what in your opinion are the leading
kind of causes of inflammation
and what are the ways that we can avoid these?
Like what are some daily habits that we can
kind of undercut this chronic immune response
that is making us sick?
So, as I mentioned,
I think one of the major drivers of inflammation
is gut health and lack of fiber.
That's really one of the major things.
So making sure you're eating enough vegetables,
getting enough, nut seeds, plants, legumes,
like I think that's very, very important
for controlling inflammation.
And that's been,
I mean, it's been shown
that the gut is a major regulator of inflammation.
So that's number one, that's easy,
you know increase your intake of vegetables.
The other easy actionable for controlling inflammation
is believe it or not actually causing acute inflammation
through exercise.
Because it is a hormetic,
it's called a hormetic type of stress
where you're inducing stress,
you're then activating all these anti-inflammatory genes.
And this has been shown like about an hour after exercise.
You have a really high elevation of
these pro-inflammatory mediators.
And then immediately after that,
like couple hours later is a very strong
anti-inflammatory response.
So exercise is a really good way to boost
the anti-inflammatory processes
and natural ones in your body-
Right, so it's like pushups
for your immune system as well as for your muscles?
Exactly, it really is.
It really is.
And the other one that I've really been obsessed
with recently is curcumin.
And curcumin is one of the two curcuminoids
that is found in tumeric.
Right, it's a root.
It's a root.
What is the difference between that and tumeric?
Well, tumeric has many different curcuminoids
in them, including curcumin.
I like to get,
now I mentioned the curcumin specifically
because the curcumin
is a very, very potent anti-inflammatory
but it doesn't work the way people may be thinking
and it's, you know, anti-inflammatory drugs.
It works very differently
because it's actually kind of like exercise.
It's a hormetic stress.
It's actually slightly toxic to us.
And because it's slightly toxic to us,
it turns on all these really potent anti-inflammatory genes
and it inhibits the pro-inflammatory ones as well.
So curcumin is really, really good at doing that
but I want to just differentiate the difference
between curcumin and tumeric.
Tumeric is also very good
because it's the source of curcumin.
Curcumin's not as concentrated
if you're taking the full tumeric,
which you can buy the route and have it fresh
or you can buy powder and cook with it.
You know, curries and stuff are often have tumeric in it
or you can make tea, you can do lots of things with it
but what's really cool about tumeric
is that in addition to curcumin,
it has something in it called aromatic tumerin
which is another curcuminoid that has a completely
different function than for curcumin.
The aromatic tumerone has been shown in studies to actually
in the brain increase neural STEM cells.
So STEM cells in the brain to make more neurons.
So it actually increases neural STEM cells
to what's called differentiate
which just means these STEM cells become neurons.
So it increased dramatically increase the number
of neurons in little mind sprains.
All right.
So back to inflammation.
So here we have increase your fiber.
We have exercise, we have curcumin.
Yes.
And then beyond that, let's talk about sleep
and other stress reduction techniques like meditation
and the impact of that on reducing chronic inflammation.
I was just going there.
Oh, you were.
Okay, sorry about that.
Yes.
Well, I've become sort of obsessed recently
with a circadian rhythm or your biological clock
which is related to sleep.
You know, humans are on a a 24 hour light or day,
night dark cycle where we're
in the day when it's light out or active,
you know we're working, we're exercising,
we're thinking we're, you know, metabolically active
at night when it's dark typically we're,
you know, resting, sleeping.
It's when we're repairing a lot of damage, things like that.
But what is so interesting is that bright light exposure,
early bright light exposure is so incredibly important
for setting your biological clock.
It's like an anchor to set it so that it knows,
okay this is day, this one day starts.
And so this internal clock that you have regulates
like 20% and a 15 and 20% of your entire genome.
Many of those genes are involved
in metabolism, inflammation-
Wow, that's true.
Tons and I mean,
it's completely regulated on chest
you know, the amount of light you're exposed to when
you're exposed to it and when it dark, it's like this clock.
And so recently I came across a study that showed
when humans were exposed to really, really bright light
it was 10,000 Lux, which is like the sun
when they're exposed to it starting early
for about seven hours
that was able to reduce cortisol levels,
which is the stress hormone cortisol by up to 25%
during the next day, during its peak phase.
Wow.
25%, so cortisol-
The translation, you need to be outside
and exposed to the sun?
I suppose you'll be sitting in your cubicle?
Yes, that's the translation.
And, you know, just cortisol is I mean
it causes massive inflammation.
It's one of those stress hormones
that activates almost every gene and the body
that increases your immune cells
to go fire, fire, fire, cortisol, there's that.
I mean, there's a reason it does that.
It's a stress response,
but if you are not being exposed to bright light
because you live somewhere and it's dark in your house
or your apartment, or you work a job where,
you're just not able to be exposed to the light,
it really can have detrimental effects on health.
And you know, we're talking about inflammation here
that's at the molecular level
that's what's going on, but it, you know
it has a lot of effects on your ability to lose weight
to gain muscle mass, your mood, brain function
memory, learning, you, all these things.
I mean, tons and tons of studies have shown,
you know cortisol decreases muscle mass.
It actually causes your muscles to atrophy,
it causes your brain to atrophy.
And this has all been shown experimentally.
Wow, that's amazing.
So for the average person though, they're not
most people are not able to be out
in direct sunlight for seven hours a day, right?
So is there like a manageable solution
for the average person?
Well, I do know that
in terms of just setting the biological clock,
being exposed to seven hours a day,
that specifically was referring
to the 25% reduction in cortisol.
I got you.
But just being exposed
to bright light for like one to two hours
is enough to set your biological clock correctly
so that your metabolism is going the way it's supposed to,
your inflammation is going the way it's designed.
You know, you're able to break down fat,
you're able to build muscle mass.
You're able to, repair damage.
All these things are being regulated
by that biological clock.
So that one to two hours is key for that,
which is like sort of like the minimal thing.
Right, right.
It's such a crazy thing that the circadian rhythm
is like even exists.
I mean, we walk around and thinking that we've mastered
nature, you know and we forget that
we're just primal creatures,
living in this basically in the wild
and that we're still, you know, we still have to fall prey
to these things beyond our control.
Okay, got it.
But how do things like stress and anxiety play
into all of this?
For example, is the trauma of this pandemic
impacting our microbiome?
And in closing what exactly is the best dietary approach
to optimizing the microbiome and microbiome health?
Hint, think plant diversity.
To close out today's Deep Dive,
let's hear from my buddy, Dr. Will Bulsiewicz,
a gastroenterologist, gut health guru,
and author of the must read "Fiber Fueled."
So many things that talk about
I think an interesting launching off point for this
would be to kind of contextualize your work
with what's going on currently
in this pandemic era that we're all navigating through.
And what I've been thinking about lately,
and I'm interested in your thoughts on,
is how we square this,
need to socially distance and sanitize our environments
and kind of cloister ourselves from other human beings
and restrict our exposure to a variety of environments
with this paramount need to increase our biodiversity
not just with the foods that we're eating
but with the environments that we visit
the people that we interact with,
like these two things are at odds,
this importance of biodiversity maximizing that
with this need to kind of over cleanse
everything at the moment.
Yeah.
I feel like health has never been as important
as it is right now.
There is a direct connection between your gut microbiome
and the strength of your immune system.
And for that reason, it becomes imperative
that we take care and nurture a healthy gut microbiome.
And the thing that sort of stands out to me, Rich,
is yes like excessive cleanliness,
sterilizing our environment, not being allowed to socialize
and connect with other humans.
Like all of those things are there.
But to me, the most powerful influence is the stress.
The stress is something that is affecting all of us.
I mean, we are living through a moment of collective stress.
We're all forced to take this on.
There's no avoiding it.
And that actually has an impact on our gut microbiome.
And it drives us to this place where we all sort of
have different ways that we cope and deal with that stress.
And for many it's to turn to unhealthy habits
and that includes unhealthy food.
And in many cases, alcohol.
And we're compounding that stress
and we're actually compounding the harm that it does
to our gut microbiome.
You know, many people, when we think about gut health
we've talked about food and like my book discusses food
in great detail.
The part of the book that I really wanted to elaborate on
and there just weren't enough pages for me to go there
is the effect of trauma.
The most challenging patients that I see
as a gastroenterologist are the people who have been victims
of physical, emotional, sexual, psychological trauma.
And it changes them.
And they don't realize the way that it affects their gut.
And typically when they get to me,
I'm the fifth or sixth doctor gastroenterologists
that they've been to.
They're looking for solutions related
to their gut microbiome or to their digestive issues.
And what I discover
after getting to know them and building that trust
and that relationship is that the solution the path
is actually not through food.
Moreso it's actually about healing
that trauma that is eating at them on a subconscious level.
And all of us are dealing with trauma right now.
And I feel like collectively
this is affecting our gut microbiome
and it's at the worst possible time.
There's a direct line
between gut health and our immune system.
70% of our immune system lives in our gut.
And when we have that,
that emotional trauma that's affecting our gut.
And then we also compound that by consuming alcohol
or by eating junk food, we're putting ourselves
into a vulnerable place where if we do get the virus
we don't have our defense system built up to protect us.
And that's the scary thing, because increasingly
we're seeing studies, Rich, that are making connections
between the gut microbiome
and severe manifestations of COVID-19.
I mean, we're, you know
the doctors are all asking the questions
who are these people, they get COVID-19?
And one of the first things that we discovered is
it's the people who are that have diabetes
and high blood pressure
and coronary artery disease and are overweight.
And then when you think about all
of those things that I just mentioned, diabetes
heart disease, high blood pressure, being overweight,
they're all connected back to the microbiome.
So essentially to ignore gut health
or to not have a optimally functioning microbiome
is to put yourself at peril in terms of your immune response
to COVID or anything?
I feel like this connection is critically important
in the 21st century period.
I mean, look at the explosion of
immune mediated disease States, you know,
look at celiac disease, at 500% in the last 50 years,
look at inflammatory bowel disease,
that's absolutely exploding.
And, you know, there's conditions,
Rich, that when I was a kid
literally didn't exist that I'm diagnosed in sometimes twice
in the same day that are immune mediated.
You know, things like eosinophilic esophogitis
and so independent of COVID.
I feel like recognizing this connection
is really critically important
because the problem is once you trip that wire
once you cross that line, you may find yourself
with one of these conditions that I don't believe
that there's necessarily a cure.
I think that you can put yourself into remission,
but once you have one of these conditions
I think that you have it.
And it's there.
In terms of the protocols that we should all
be undertaking to, you know, buttress our microbiome,
you're not necessarily advising a specific type of diet
other than to say, plant diversity is King.
Like, this is the vector of all factors for you, right?
So it's not about,
Oh, is vegan or, I mean, it's a predominantly
plant-based or plant-based diet
but the diversity of plants is really what's important
in terms of making sure that you're doing everything you can
in the interest of your microbiome?
Well, I think the critical piece to me,
so, you know the book is called "Fiber Fuels"
and that's because I feel like fiber has been this
ignored superfood.
And part of it is that we've been thinking
about it as this orange drink that grandma's stirs
up so that she can poop.
When in fact it's incredible, the connection between fiber
and our gut microbiome.
You know, fiber doesn't just go in the mouth
and shoot out the other end.
Soluble fiber is a specific sort of category
which feeds the microbiome.
This is their preferred food.
When we give this to them, they consume it.
They grow stronger.
Our microbes actually multiply, grow stronger.
And then they turn around and they reward us.
And the way that they reward us is by releasing
short chain, fatty acids.
And these short chain fatty acids have healing effects
throughout the entire body.
So, you know, we've been emphasizing a little bit
the immune system.
Short chain, fatty acids optimize our immune system.
There are studies that we could talk about,
if you want to, connecting short chain fatty acids
in terms of protection from respiratory viruses,
they can have their effect in the lungs
on the immune system.
Short chain fatty acids, reverse leaky gut,
you know, which is, I mean dysbiosis.
That is the root cause of these digestive issues
that I take care of on a daily basis.
They directly prevent colon cancer.
They lower our cholesterol and they prevent and reverse
insulin resistance, which is Type II Diabetes.
They travel throughout the entire body
having their human effects.
We think that they can actually
reverse coronary artery disease.
We think that they can actually repair
the blood brain barrier for people that have brain fog.
They actually travel into the brain
through the blood brain barrier and they have their effects.
They affect our mood, our memory,
they affect, I mean believe it or not,
we have studies that suggest
that they prevent Alzheimer's disease.
These are incredibly powerful.
And the way that you get them is through the consumption
of fiber in your diet.
And here's the problem.
97% of Americans are not getting an adequate amount
of fiber in their diet.
And that's creating issues for us.
Everybody is worried about their protein intake
but they don't give a second thought to their fiber intake.
97% of people are fiber deficient.
I mean, that's a shocking statistic.
You know, and that's what the most standards.
I mean the expectation or the standard that we're holding
is 25 grams for women and 38 grams for men.
And the average American is somewhere
in the 15 to 18 gram range.
And you know, Rich, let me ask you a question.
I'm just curious.
So I know you eat a very healthy diet.
If you had to estimate in a given week,
how many plants do you think you have in your diet?
Give me a general idea.
I mean it's going to be higher than most
but it can't be more than, I mean, 30, 40.
Okay, and I would challenge the people
listening at home right now.
Like if you have to hit the pause button,
take a minute and think about how many plants
you actually have in your diet.
So most Americans are definitely less than 30.
The majority are around 15 to 20.
There are literally 300,000 edible plants on the planet.
The problem is that we've narrowed it down
to the point where 75% of our diet is from three of them.
You know, and we're ignoring this diversity.
You know, we've put pressure, unfortunately
on our farmers where the farmer has no choice
but to opt for high yield breeds of crops.
We are narrowing down the biodiversity within our diet
through our food systems.
If there's only one thing that you take away
from this podcast, listening to us
have this conversation today
this is what I want you guys to hear.
The way that it works is this, fiber is not just fiber.
There are millions, if not billions
of types of fiber in nature.
It's so incredibly complicated from a chemistry
perspective that we're not even capable
of creating an estimate to how many types
of fiber there are.
But every single plan has its own unique types of fiber.
Multiple different types within that plant.
Every single plant is going to have prebiotic fiber
that feeds the microbiome.
This is their preferred food, these prebiotic fibers.
And the key is that they are picky eaters.
They're like us, you have different food preferences
than I do, even though I'm sure
that many people would label us as having the same diet.
You eat differently than I do.
We have our own preferences and they do too.
They have specific food preferences
in terms of the different types of fiber.
You know, to put in the perspective, take a black bean.
You give these microbes a black bean,
and there are certain specific species
that are going to multiply and thrive.
And they're going to be stronger and be more prepared to
help you because you just fed that they are energized,
but the opposite is true.
You take that black bean away,
you say I'm going black bean free,
those same microbes that were thriving
because you were feeding them, are starving.
Right.
And they're not getting what they need.
And so the point is we want as much diversity as possible,
and that's the critical piece.
Eating as many different things as possible
and getting out of your comfort zone a little bit.
And I think that what you're saying essentially is
that the more that you're in the practice of doing that
it's almost like an insurance policy
that you're taking out for your gut health.
You're seeding your gut with the biota
that will then ultimately be able to grow and thrive.
The more that you're feeding it, those types of plants.
Yeah.
Every single plant has its own unique types of fiber.
That's what I've been talking about
for the last few minutes, but there's so much more.
Every single plant has vitamins minerals, phytochemicals.
These are the unique chemicals that you will find
in plant foods exclusive to plant foods.
That's what phyto means.
There's at least 8,000 of them.
Very few of them have we actually studied.
An example of one is resveratrol.
So you hear about resveratrol,
you know, resveratrol is capable
of actually changing the microbiome by itself.
You know, David Sinclair in "Lifespan" talks
about resveratrol and its benefits for healthy aging.
And this is just one example
of one phytochemical that you will find in these plants.
And the other thing, by the way, that's kind of interesting,
most people don't realize this,
the plants have a microbiome of their own.
Every single life on this planet
either has a microbiome or is a part of the microbiome.
And depending on how you choose to zoom out
you could almost make the argument that us humans
are a part of a larger microbiome in a way,
which is planetary health and the way that it all functions.
But these plants have their own microbiome.
If you take an apple, for example
cause we have a study that shows this,
the Apple has a microbiome that is there
from like literally the seed through the flower
and all the way through to the fruit.
And that microbiome is dynamically evolving
and changing and helping this to actually
this transformational process to occur.
And the apple has literally
over 1,000 species of microbes, more than us humans do
and hunt potentially 100 million microbes.
When you eat an Apple, you're getting the fiber,
you're getting the phytochemicals of which there are many
you're getting the vitamins and the minerals
and you're even getting the microbiome
that the apple contains.
Right, wow.
And so each plant has a story like that.
Each plant has something positive
that it wants to bring to your health.
Every single one wants to bring something to your health.
Yeah, and what's interesting
about the work that you do is that it's not about
reducing certain things.
You're talking about what you're building,
like what you're at.
It's very additive like this whole diversification
of your diet is about building new things into your diet
as opposed to focusing on what we're removing.
I feel like it's easily applicable
but conceptually extremely sound like from my perspective
50 years from now,
this is still going to be the best way to eat
to consume a broad variety of plants,
to be as predominantly plant-based as possible.
You know and I wrote the book, Rich,
to meet people where they are.
So, you know, when you say,
well you're not originally inherent to any particular diet
I want people to be 90% to 100% plant based.
That's what we find in the blue zones.
That's what I think
from a nutritional perspective is the highest quality diet.
And I do think that when people get to be 90%, plant-based
they're going to feel so good.
They're going to want to keep going.
But I also think that there's an argument
that goes beyond nutrition and talks about
the health of our planet
and talks about, you know, the compassion for these animals.
And I think that those should be a part of the conversation
even if they are not directly human nutrition.
I think the COVID-19 has taught us
that when we abuse this planet, we may abuse these animals.
I kind of feel like it's going to fight back.
It's beautifully put.
And that just speaks to the interrelationship of everything.
You can't talk about the microbiome
without referencing the macrobiome.
The health of our gut is related
to the health of the planet and vice versa.
The soil health connects to human health.
You know, the health of our soil
which is the source of our nutrients is critically important
to human populations moving forward.
I have children and I am scared
of what this planet looks like 100 years from now
when you consider what it looks like today compared to 1920.
And the reality is that
we need to just look at population.
Right now, we have 7 billion people.
In 2050 we will have 10 billion people.
Consider that in 1900, there were only 2 billion people.
Consider that an 1800 there was only 1 billion people.
We're going to have 10 times the population in 250 years.
And that's putting a strain on the environment,
on our planet.
A strain on these animals.
Biodiversity is the word it's critical to our gut health.
It's critical to planetary health and it needs to be upheld.
Thanks for listening everybody.
Hope you enjoyed this first in what we are planning
will be a series of topics
specific, Deep Dives that we intend to drip out
over the course of the coming year.
As I mentioned in the introduction links
to the full episodes for today's featured guests
can be found in the show notes
on the episodepage@richroll.com.
If you would like to support the podcast,
the easiest and most impactful thing you can do
is to subscribe to the show on Apple podcasts, Spotify
and YouTube.
Sharing the show, or your favorite episode
with friends or on social media is of course
always appreciated.
That's amazing.
And finally, for podcast updates, special offers on books
"The Meal Planner" and other subjects,
subscribe to our newsletter,
which you can find on the footer of anypage@richroll.com.
Today's show was produced and engineered by Jason Camiolo.
The video edition of the podcast was created
by Blake Curtis, portraits by Allie Rogers,
David Greenberg and Leimara Savage
Gaphic elements, courtesy of Jessica Miranda,
copywriting by Georgia Whaley
and our theme music was created
by Tyler Piatt, Trapper Piat, and Harry Nathas.
Appreciate the love.
Love the support.
Thank you for listening.
Be back here soon.
Peace.